hey Dr. Berg here in this short little
video we want to talk about a great
success
so we're talking about blood pressure
now before we get started I want to just
let you know we're not making any claims
to cure blood pressure or any medical
diseases what I do is I like to work
with the person's medical doctor as a
kind of a team to work on the nutrition
part to help them increase health so
then they can reduce the medication so
now you were on some medications tell us
a little bit about medications you're on
and your blood pressure was pretty high
right yes I was taking lipitor beta
blocker and Norwex and I forget the
other ones it was a concoction of few
different medications basically very
high blood pressure 160 by 110 and since
I've been coming to you and seeing but
now for for a while I you introduced me
to d3 and k2 and when I started to do
that along with the kale juice and all
that my blood pressure kept on going
down and my physician kept on reducing
the dosage of the medication that I was
taking and actually I'm completely off
the medication and I actually have low
blood pressure at some times just came
off of the month of fasting in which it
was a little difficult to take the D in
the d3 and k2
maybe transposing the numbers but any
event I'm back on track and I'm taking
four and four everyday and my blood
pressure is completely normal I would
say about 120 by 75 which is remarkable
even with the medication I was taking I
was 135 hundred and thirty by eighty
eighty-five but now without medication I
am even lowered that's interesting
because you know the medication
obviously was not working
your wife is the radiologist and I'm
sure she was happy that you're kind of
reducing your medications but I want to
explain what k2 is in d3
vitamin d3 in k2 don't directly fix
blood pressure what they do is they help
mobilize calcium in the arteries and you
yeah I'm going to I'm going to get to
that and so the calcium that plugs up
the pipe sort of speak to vessels and
they makes it more like hardened
arteries the blood pressure go up
because they K 2 and D 3 and I like to
do like four of each per day I like the
D 3 to be 10,000 IU's and the K 2 to be
at 100 micrograms and take four of each
in the morning and then what happens is
that it starts to mobilize calcium out
of the vessels not just the heart valves
and the blood vessels but the arteries
through the carotid through the neck up
into the brain because you had a problem
when you tilt your neck back remember
you actually had pain yeah I could not
do this and I could not lie down and
look up and the whole you know I I used
to the the ceiling would be turning and
I don't have that problem and the only
thing I'm doing different is really
taking these three and you had predicted
that that that's what triggered actually
you putting me on those things and also
inside of my teeth I just had my
hygienist she felt that I had a lot more
of calcium or deposits on my inside of
the teeth and now I'm going every three
months so there was certainly a surplus
of calcium buildup which my body I
apparently was releasing and it was
sticking to my teeth what happens is
that k2 helps mobilize calcium out of
the wrong place and and it helps get it
out of the system if there is an excess
amount and sometimes it can come out
through the pores of your body
I've had even someone coming out of the
tear ducts but most the time it just
goes into the bone so yeah so anything
like soft tissue calcium arthritis
bursitis tendinitis blood pressure
calcium buildup in the joints where
you're really stiff can clear up with
these two nutrients so it's it's it's
such a no-brainer I think within the
next three four years you're going to
see a lot of people doing this
combination because it handles so many
issues with people I mean as people get
older they turn into a stone they become
very very stiff and they get heart
problems women that take calcium without
the k2 and the d3 end up with a lot of
problems with the heart so even the
medication for blood pressure one of the
medications is calcium channel blockers
what's that that is a medication to get
the calcium out of the heart right now
they're doing even a better scan for for
the heart which is a calcium scan they
looked for plaquing calcium which is
much better than so cholesterol is a
whole different thing over here but
calcium is a and more important
indicator right now for overall health
so I just wanted to say this is awesome
and thank you for sticking to it in your
success and I wish you the best in the
future thank you very much you're
welcome